this morning on the dish the real food
of india from chef chintan pandia and
restaurateur rani mazumdar the duo's
latest eatery demaca earned a spot on a
new york times list of the city's best
new restaurants and was nominated by the
james beard foundation as one of
america's best new venues with chef
pondia singled out as one of new york's
best chefs
i sat down with the pair to talk about
their winning recipe for street to table
indian cuisine
on the lower east side of manhattan the
hot ticket in town is a table in this
corner of the historic essex market
not even owner ronnie mizundar and chef
chintin padya we have a policy where i
can't take a reservation can maneuver a
last-minute reservation here i can book
a month in advance i can put a request
in for month in advance and get it like
a normal person yeah but i cannot walk
in a day before and say that i need a
table tomorrow icon so basically this is
my shot
yeah
damaca has ignited a mantra
unapologetically indian and no wonder
the name itself means explosion the goal
is to demystify indian food i feel that
if we don't really put out there who we
really are
we can't blame people for not loving it
in bringing their restaurant to life the
duo keep to their roles i'm the business
side of it he's a chef he cooks when you
want to scare away people
that's the only time the guy cooks and
you're okay with this description uh yes
we both know our weaknesses and our
strengths and what we don't do
is we don't step into each other's
business we give each other that utmost
trust
tell me some was the graffiti part of
the aesthetic
it wasn't we tried our best to clean all
of these up at some point we stopped
because we said you know what this is
lower east side
let it be the lower east side has long
serviced the spectrum of newcomers to
this nation
the essex market has been an institution
since being established 80 years ago as
a grocery hub for jewish and italian
immigrants it closed before the pandemic
and relocated across the street with
damaca front and center you know i guess
at the end it's not about if the
restaurant is big small all the
accolades take everything away what you
really have is a couple of us
immigrants just sharing our cuisine
in the way we want to and i think that
makes us no different than anybody else
that's in the market and that's what
we're celebrating muzumdar moved to new
york from calcutta when he was 12.
pandya from mumbai in 2013. they opened
their first restaurant together in 2017
and owned three more all under the
banner of unapologetic foods i was also
that kid that was trying to fit in high
school or junior high and felt ashamed
for what the food was being cooked at my
home so i would tell my mom not to cook
that fish curry because my friends are
coming home i've been through that as if
like there's something i'm doing wrong
and i think it's not just me every
single immigrant in this country has
shares a similar emotion and somewhere
there came a point
for both of us was that
i think it's time we really share who we
are the result what they call provincial
dishes inspired by pondia's travels
across india where he sampled food from
street carts and homes in small villages
i was cooking to impress others and i
think the day you stop doing that and
start cooking what you love to eat
the product changes you're sharing it
sharing it this is what i want to eat
it's a real dish it's not like i want to
sell you this this is no it's something
that i love to eat do you want to be
part of that experience for this duo
unapologetic indian cuisine looks like
this spice meat on the bone fish on the
bone and you start to see the vessels
that they're cooked in on our table we
have pressure cooker palau now when you
go to a regular restaurant when you eat
a palau it's cooked rice and cooked
chicken but this one is actually made
from raw rice it only gets cooked when
you order it mur kofta a chicken
meatball stuffed with an egg and that's
a cashew based sauce this is dal tadka
dal is lentil kadka means tempering so
this tempering is done table side in a
regular setting this is called chapati
it's a patty
yeah this is one of the most common
breads that we eat and that's a paratha
pork salad house made paneer we only
have one kind of a cheese a fresh cheese
which is a paneer and whole fried
pomfret oh my gosh that's perfectly
seasoned an indian menu as diverse as
the country and it's 1.3 billion
residents it is three times the
population of america but if you
consider the land it is third so it's a
very dense populated country and the
cuisine keeps on changing every few
miles or 50 60 miles so when you think
of indian food
you're essentially trying most of the
stuff from northwest got it and you're
contributing that as all of india
what the purpose of this restaurant is
is to put a spotlight on those regions
that are overlooked we call this this is
the other side of india oh you're eating
that together this is what we used to do
man look at you oh boy you're getting
there pandia showed me how to make one
of his favorite street foods
we are doing this dish it's called papri
chaat it's with flour little bit of you
know spices everything inside it and
it's deep fried and chaat is like a
generic word for a street food in india
crumbled potatoes tamarind chutney
excellent little bit more then we have
the sweetened yogurt yogurt sauce crisps
and what pandia calls the magic spice
the spice blend i like spice that's it
perfect not too much so
dig it in take all the layers
okay i'm feeling the heat now i told you
and the customers are eating it up too
a testament to this team's authenticity
as they change the face of indian
cuisine
what people want to feel is first
something that's real so all we can do
is put what's real what's our truth
our with our integrity out there on the
table and once people feel that i think
it will inspire a whole new generation
of people that will start to think that
this is okay
[Music]
my aha moment was knowing now that what
we're used to is just a sliver of india
yeah and you know there's so much more
to explore cannot wait to taste it
another feast for the eyes is next
remarkable images from around the world
submitted to an international
competition will give you a taste of
some of the best you're watching cbs
saturday morning
so i've i brought a feast of plenty here
you did and i'm sitting there like jeff
do not eat yet you cannot yes still have
to get to that first cheese well so i
want to make sure i get this right so
this is biryani right it's braised goat
with basmati rice and saffron and then
of course we brought a nice little
cocktail it's called the pond cocktail
the pun pun oh p-a-a-n right so it's gin
batelle leaf
um
domain canton and ginger i don't know
what that is but it's some liqueur how
do you like it
it's good it's got a kick to it oh the
drink i'm eating the food the drink is
interesting oh yeah it is right right
it's like a green juice with alcohol but
you know jeff really you're not supposed
to eat with a knife and fork
you really need to dig i asked you if i
could do that i'm happy to do that let's
see you do it let's let's see if you
know how to
you got to join
you just got to dig in get it up and you
now you got it usually it's and then
it's like you push it
into the show why do they why do they
with their hair why
many cultures eat with their hands i
learned to do it in eastern africa in
kenya
but it's just it tastes better when it's
from
straight off the plate into your mouth
as opposed to putting a metal utensil
with your mouth full now jeff right with
the metal utensil because it dulls the
flavor it also changes the flavor yeah
yeah exactly
so let me see jeff can i see it it did i
just did i mean i think it tastes the
same
[Laughter]
regardless but anyway